- There's something really appealing
with anything, to taking it apart,
and finding out how it works.
It's like seeing the world
through the eyes of a kid.
How does this work?
You take it apart and figure it out,
and we don't get to do that with
phones and computers because
they're inscrutable.
They're black boxes.
But something that's got gears and metal
and screws and things in it
that is fully powered by a little spring
that's inside of it,
that you can take apart and
figure out how it works.
I'm Samir Patel, Deputy
Editor of Atlas Obscura,
and we're in mid-town Manhattan at the
Horological Society of New York.
- [Nick] Hello welcome.
- Hey, Samir.
- Samir, nice to meet you.
I'm Nick.
- [Samir] I'm about to take
a class in watchmaking.
So I think we're gonna take
a mechanical watch movement,
and take the entire thing apart,
and put the entire thing back together.
I think it's going to go super poorly,
but I'm gonna do my best,
and we'll see if I can not completely
destroy this watch movement.
- [Nick] My name is Nicholas Manousos.
I'm the President of the
Horological Society of New York.
We're housed in the General
Society building on 44th Street.
The Horological Society
was founded in 1866
and is one of the world's
oldest continuously
operating watchmaking associations.
Today, we are a 501c3 non-profit
and we focus on education.
Education for the public.
Our mission is to teach
as many people as possible
everything about horology.
We're going to teach horology 101,
then we teach the basics of what makes
a mechanical watch tick.
So now we're gonna take
a look at the tools
that you have in front of you.
- [Samir] Yeah.
- [Nick] So the correct way
to use these screwdrivers
is to hold them like this
and put your pointer finger
on the top.
So, what this does is it
stabilizes the screwdriver.
[Samir] Yup.
[Nick] And the tweezers are
pretty similar to the ones
you probably have at home
except that they're very sharp.
I have stabbed myself with them before.
It's not fun.
Anytime you want to touch something,
hold something down, push
something in the movements,
instead of using your finger,
we use the plastic point instead.
And of course the loupe.
So, the loupe is a magnifying glass
you wear over one of your eyes.
Okay, so let's get into it.
- [Nick] So the first step
before taking apart the watch is
letting the power down.
It's kinda like a car.
If you're gonna work on
the engine of the car,
you would turn the
engine off first, right?
So you're kinda gonna wanna
brace using your pinky,
and then also get the
pointer in your hand.
- My fingers have never felt
so fat than they do right now.
I knew basically how timekeeping works,
but just to understand when you
look at the back of a watch,
or the inside of a movement,
what all these pieces are,
and how they work in harmony,
that's something I
don't feel like you feel
until you actually take it apart
and try and put it back together.
So I was trying to watch where
you were putting your fingers
because holding the
thing is not necessarily
the most intuitive thing
to hold multiple things at once.
- [Nick] There are certain
parts in watch movements
that require coordination,
like putting a train-wheeled
bridge back into place,
you need to line up three
different wheels at the same time.
Each of those wheels
has a pivot that needs
to be in the exactly same place,
and so watchmaking is not just
putting things together.
It's also practicing focusing
and kinda meditating and
getting into the right zone
to be able to get things
back together again
inside of the mechanical movement.
[Samir] They're all right there,
they're all like
kissing the purple from the jewels but...
[Nick] You're very, very
close at this point.
There you go.
[Samir] That did it.
- [Nick] That's it.
- [Samir] I just felt it click into place.
- [Nick] That was it, yup.
- [Samir] The experience
of learning from Nick
was great because every time
something wasn't working
he would come in
immediate and diagnose it.
It was often something simple like
I wasn't holding the screwdriver straight.
He would say, tilt the screwdriver towards
your head a little bit,
and then the screw would fall into place,
and I would stop slipping
all over the place.
It's clear he knows what he's doing
and he knows what the pitfalls are
that people run into when they're
learning how to do this.
- [Samir] My favorite
part was when you take
the balance wheel and the
balance spring and you
dangle it, and it's
trembling in your fingers,
and you set it down and
you bring your hand around,
and drop it with your tweezers,
and the watch just springs to life.
[Nick] Perfect.
Good job.
You did it.
[Samir] That's it, thank you.
- [Nick] Congratulations.
You did a great job.
You've got a second career in watchmaking
if you ever wanna make the switch.
[Samir] Don't tempt me.
- [Nick] I love teaching
new students because
the students come into the class
and they may be nervous,
or they may not know exactly
what they're going to be doing,
and getting them through the entire class
to the very last step when they put the
balance wheel back into the watch,
and they see the watch come to life,
it's magical.
I see a smile come across their face
and it makes me feel good knowing that
I've taught them a little
something about horology,
about mechanical watches,
and it's just a good feeling
at the end of the day.
I really enjoy teaching.